[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETE LEPAGE: All right,
welcome, everybody.
My name's Pete LePage.
And today, joining me we have
Brad Frost, who's going to be
talking to us about some
rather cool stuff.
Brad, I'll leave it to you
to introduce yourself.
This is a reschedule of
an event that we had a
little while ago.
So welcome, and I'll turn
it over to you.
BRAD FROST: Yeah.
Thanks, Pete.
Thanks for having me.
I appreciate it.
So yeah, my name is Brad Frost
and I am a mobile web
strategist and front end
designer at an agency RGA,
which is based in New York, but
I'm broadcasting to you
from beautiful Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania.
So I've been spending a lot of
time talking about responsive
design verses separate
mobile design for
the last couple years.
So that'll do it.
In case you have been living
under a rock, you probably
realized that we had an election
not that long ago.
So that's what we're going to
talk about, is we're going to
talk about the presidential
candidates' mobile web strategy.
So this is the "Responsive
Design versus Separate Mobile
Sites Presidential Smackdown
Edition."
So let's get started.
This is a dead horse.
And this is a picture of me
beating that dead horse.
A lot has been talked about
regarding responsive design
versus making a separate mobile
website, which route to
go, which one to choose.
There's been a lot of great
articles, like this one, this
one, this one.
Google weighing in
a little bit.
Facebook's developers blog.
So a lot of people have a lot of
different opinions on which
way to go, what's best for your
organization as far as
what mobile web strategy
you want to choose.
But really, the ultimate answer
is that it depends.
It really depends on the way
your company is structured,
what your budget is, what sort
of team you have in place,
what sort of technologies you're
working in, you're
proficient in, and all
of that good stuff.
So really, it's not a black
and white answer.
So if you're expecting one,
sorry about that.
So why are we bothering
talking about this?
Why am I tearing apart the
presidential candidates'
websites and making
them look so bad?
Really, because I'm a terrible
human being.
Actually, no.
That's not true.
I'm trying to be constructive
here.
But what it really comes down
to is that very rarely do we
have an apples to apples
comparison of when to use a
certain strategy.
There's a lot of factors
at play.
Time is a big one.
So even if you were to have a
separate mobile site, and then
redo it into a responsive
website, you're
in a different time.
The web landscape, the device
landscape has shifted.
People's behavior has shifted.
More people are getting
online.
So could you really chalk any
success or failure up to a
specific technique?
Maybe, maybe not.
Again, it all depends.
So very rarely do we have
something that's actually a
very black and white comparison
between two
different strategies.
But that's exactly what
we have for this
presidential election.
You have two candidates trying
to accomplish the exact same
thing using the exact same
mediums, only they've decided
to go different routes.
So that's why this is sort of
such an attractive case study
because really, all the other
variables are control variables.
You're going after the
same audience.
You're going after
the same goals.
There's no difference in what
they're trying to accomplish.
So let's take a look at the
candidates' websites.
This is Barack Obama's
website and this is
Mitt Romney's website.
And for the keen observers out
there, you'll probably notice
something--
splash screens are back
in full effect.
Why they went that
way is beyond me.
But yeah, so splash screens.
Apparently splash screens
are still
relevant in 2012, or something.
But this one's my favorite.
Are you in?
In the website?
No, I am not.
Please let me.
So once you get beyond these
little terrible splash
screens, you look at something
that resembles
something like a website.
So this is Barack Obama's
website and this is Mitt
Romney's website.
Sort of similar feel to both
of them, so makes very good
comparison.
So again, these are the desktop
versions of the site.
So we have to ask ourselves an
important question, why bother
with the mobile web?
Why are these candidates
spending any time optimizing
their websites for
mobile devices?
Well, we have sort of
some naysayers.
We have, oh, here we go again
with the separate mobile
versus responsive
design debate.
I predict in the future people
will get sick and tired of
using their mobile device as the
primary means of using the
internet and go back to using
a nice 27-inch flatscreen
monitor where they can see
everything, interact with
everything, and actually type on
a real keyboard versus all
this touchscreen nonsense.
We are cultivating a nation
of slide-swiping,
screen-surfing zombies.
Well, Ken.
Despite your best attempts at
sounding like a huge jerk,
this is pretty awesome.
That line is pretty amazing.
We are cultivating a nation
of slide-swiping,
screen-surfing zombies.
That's just great.
I mean, that's what's
happening.
We have a population that
is increasingly mobile.
If you look at the United
States population, it's
sitting somewhere around
311 million people.
55% of US adults access the web
through a mobile device.
And that number is growing it
seems every single month.
The number gets bigger.
In addition, a full 31% of
mobile web capable smartphone
users access the web primarily
through a mobile device.
That is how they primarily
get online.
Either it's the only way they
get online or absolutely the
primary way that they're
accessing web.
This is a pretty huge deal.
And what that translates to in
the eyes of the candidates--
so the presidential
candidates--
is votes, right?
You have this whole population
that's mobile
first or mobile only.
And really, getting in touch
with them through the mobile
web is one of the best ways
to get in touch with them.
If they have a desktop only
website, it might be missing
out on a huge chunk
of the population.
So we have all these different
things that are driving to the
mobile web.
We have SMS smart links.
We have my favorite thing in
the world, QR codes, which
open the browser, which
open web pages.
We have email marketing,
which the candidates
made ample use of.
And email usage on mobile
devices is skyrocketing.
A lot of people use their
mobile device
to check their email.
That's one of the most
common tasks.
Again, you receive
a campaign email.
You click a link, it
opens the browser.
You have all these different
social media channels--
Twitter, Facebook, Google+,
all that good stuff, all
driving to the web.
You share pictures.
You share text status updates,
but you also share links.
And those links open the web.
You have search engine traffic,
and direct traffic,
and referral traffic, and all of
these things are driving to
the web on mobile devices.
So it matters more and more
to care about this.
So if we take a look at what the
candidates did with their
respective sites, this
is Barack Obama's
site on a small screen.
And this is Mitt Romney's
mobile site or
m.mittromney.com.
So Mitt Romney has basically
gone and made a separate
mobile site that exists at an
m. location, while Barack
Obama's is all sitting
under one roof in
a responsive design.
So we have to ask another
important question, why would
anybody visit the candidate's
website?
That's a really important
question to ask.
So I've broken it down into
two different sort of
categories of users.
We have more information-based
users and we have more
action-based users.
So information people are
looking for the candidates'
biographies, where they stand on
issues, upcoming events in
the local area pertinent
to the person viewing,
mythbusting, things like Obama
wants me to marry a penguin.
No, no he doesn't.
He gets to write back on his
own website and bust some
myths of things living out
there in the media.
And then also, just general
news updates.
Who the candidates chose as
their vice president picks and
all tat good stuff.
On the action side of things, we
have things like donations,
which is a huge, huge driver,
and the candidates make sure
not to leave that button
out, the donate button.
Volunteer, free events, you can
sign up for local events,
participate in your community
on behalf of the candidate.
And spread the word via
social networks
and all of that stuff.
And then, of course, buy
some swag from their
official shops there.
So those are the sort of whys.
Why are the candidates
caring about this?
Why do users care about this?
Why are we even bothering with
this in the first place?
So we need some criteria in
which to analyze and compare
these sites.
And Christopher Layon is a
mobile web strategist based
out of Minnesota.
And he came up with a really
clever way of looking at the
basic needs of a mobile
web user, or
just a web user really.
And it's based on Maslow's
hierarchy of needs.
We, as human beings,
have certain needs.
And some of those needs are more
important than others.
Some are prerequisites
for achieving the
next level of self.
So at the bottom of the
heap, we have our
physiological needs.
We need to be able to breathe.
We need to be able to eat, and
drink, and sleep, and all of
that stuff.
So that's really important.
But then, as you climb the
pyramid a little bit, we have
a sense of safety, a sense
of love, a sense of
self-actualization, and
all of that stuff.
So those are sort of considered
nice-to-haves
whenever you put them
side by side to
something like breathing.
So what Christopher did was
something very clever.
And he basically translated
those into the
needs of a web user.
So basically, he broke it down
into our ability to see and
navigate, to be able to read,
to be able to respond and
share, performance
is in there.
And then he's using the term
HTML5 as sort of as a way of
talking about enhancing a web
experience to take advantage
of some of the newer
HTML5 capabilities.
So what I've done is I've gone
ahead-- and I really liked
that idea-- and I took it and
sort of just simplified it a
little bit and broke it down
into these 4 areas.
We first need to be able
to access something.
We then need to be able
to interact with it.
It needs to be highly
performant.
And we need to take advantage
of all of the various
enhancements.
So let's start with access as it
is the most important part
of the pyramid.
So these are devices.
And even though I'm coming to
you over the interwebs and I
can't hear you, I think I still
heard an audible sigh.
This is the environment
we are living with.
This is the device landscape.
And it's a pretty
humbling sight.
This is really only just a
small smattering of the
devices that are out there.
Luke Wroblewski just posted in
an article recently that said
something like 33 major devices
were released in the
last 2 months.
And so it's just becoming this
staggering pace of change.
And we, as web developers, as
web designers, we need to pay
attention to all of that.
We need to know how to deal with
it because it's becoming
unruly pretty damn quick.
So it's important to understand
that the power of
the web is its ubiquity.
If you look back at this image,
no native platform, no
iOS app, no Android app, no
Windows Phone app, no any
native or proprietary
solution can reach
all of these devices.
But the web can.
Any time you find yourself in
a native versus web debate,
just show them a picture
like this.
And just say, oh, I'm sorry.
Can your solution reach
all of these devices?
I'm not saying that native
apps are worthless.
Quite the contrary.
But at the same time, the web's
level of reach is, by
and large, the web
super power.
And because of that, we
need to preserve and
embrace that fact.
We can't continue arbitrarily
locking people out just
because we don't like what
configuration they have.
PETE LEPAGE: Folks, it looks
like we may have
lost Brad for a sec.
Let's see if we can
get him back.
Hang on.
One sec.
All right.
Well, always kind of fun dealing
with technology.
Brad's sitting in Pittsburgh
right now and I'm sitting here
in New York.
But it looks like
we've lost him.
So let's give him a second to
join back in and see if we can
get him back on.
All right.
Let's see.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRAD FROST: I lost you there.
PETE LEPAGE: Hey, no problem.
I'll get you back one sec.
Hang on.
BRAD FROST: Can you hear me?
PETE LEPAGE: I can hear
you now, yep.
BRAD FROST: OK.
Oh, sorry about that.
PETE LEPAGE: That's OK.
You're coming back
up in one sec.
BRAD FROST: That's pretty odd.
I can't hear you, Pete.
OK.
My other computer seem
to have frozen.
So I'm just going to share
my screen again.
And then we can continue on.
All right, sorry about
that everybody.
Technical difficulties.
Share my desktop.
And we're good to go.
Pete, can I get a thumbs up?
All right, perfect.
Thank you very much.
So where were we?
Yeah, Tim Berners-Lee drove this
point home at the opening
ceremony of the Olympics where
he said, this is for everyone.
Regardless of race, religion,
color, creed, location, mobile
carrier, we all have the
right to the web.
So we have to stop thinking in
sort of these myopic ways.
"Mobile users won't do
that," is something
that we commonly hear.
That's absolute horse shit.
Or elephant shit.
Or donkey shit, whatever
you prefer.
Mobile users will do anything
and everything desktop users
will do, provided is presented
in a usable way.
So we can't stop thinking,
or we have to stop
thinking of the web--
as the mobile web as
the web light.
How many people are used to
seeing something like this?
Sorry, that page is
not supported on
mobile at this time.
We don't allow mobile devices
on Tee Madness.
FollowMyHealth currently
requires a desktop browser.
A mobile version will
be available soon.
Giving us that false sense
of hope, right?
"The page you are trying to
visit is currently available
on our full HTML
site." Doritos,
no gallery, no articles.
You're using an unsupported
browser even though you're on
a very capable Android device.
Pizza Hut.
This is a really robust
single-page scrolling website,
but it says, "This site was
designed to be viewed on
standard desktops, laptops, and
tablets only." Blah, blah,
blah, blah, some long-winded
excuse.
"This website contains media
too rich for a mobile web
browser." like, I can't
be bothered
with you peasant device.
This is Google.
Sorry, guys.
But this is actually
for Google Mobile
Web Initiative thing.
And it says, "Alternately, we
suggest checking out the site
from your tablet if you have
one." I'm not really quite
sure what you would call
that guy right there.
That looks like a
tablet to me.
This is my favorite
one, though.
"This page has to be ideally
opened on your laptop or
desktop browser.
Once you open this link on your
computer, then you will
have a QR code to the URL that
needs to be opened on your
device."
Holy crap.
So really, what we're
talking about here
is the one web principle.
I'm sure we've all heard that.
I talk a lot about achieving
content parity across devices.
The term "thematic consistency,"
which was dubbed
by the W3C to talk about how web
experiences can look and
function differently provided
that the information's still
presentable in some way,
shape, or form.
But really what I found to be
really beneficial is to just
be-- to talk about it in very
common sense language.
Say, give people
what they want.
If they click on a link,
they have an
expectation for something.
And it's up to us to provide
that [INAUDIBLE] and meet that
expectation.
So if we take a look at Mitt
Romney's site, this is
actually a previous edition
of Mitt Romney's site.
You get to see sort of a
breakdown of the desktop site
in the left, and then the mobile
site in the right.
But if you look at the
navigation in the mobile site,
you'll see that only a few
options out of the desktop
site appear on the mobile
version of the site.
So that's really bad.
And it leaves a lot of
questions unanswered.
Like, who is this guy?
There's no way to access
his biography.
Where does he stand on issues
there's no way to access that
information.
What about his plan for jobs?
What can he do for my state?
Where could I shop?
All of those things were
inaccessible from the mobile
version of the website.
And again, for a lot of people,
they might not know to
click the Full Desktop Link.
And as a result, they're just
going to go elsewhere for
their information, which
certainly could be biased in
some way, shape, or form.
So thankfully, they
did a redesign
that did a lot better.
They redesigned the site.
The desktop site looks
different.
The mobile site looks
And you could see that the menu
now contains all of the
sections of the desktop
site, which is good.
In responsive design, it does a
lot better job of achieving
content parity just
because everything
exists under one roof.
But that doesn't mean
that it, by default,
achieves content parity.
A lot of times--
and a lot of sites do this--
will simply hide content
from mobile viewers.
So the site on the left is a
blog and it says, but, hey,
that's just my opinion.
Feel free to shoot me down
in the comments.
However, the comments and the
comment form are hidden for
small screen users.
So there's no comments, which
obviously is a bad thing.
On the right is navigation
with a lot of
important-sounding links.
Post a Job, About Us, Our
Guarantee, Contact Us.
All of that stuff sounds really,
really important.
But because space is constrained
on a small mobile
device, they've simply hidden
all of the navigation elements
for small screens, rendering
those things totally
inaccessible.
So if you look at Barack Obama's
redesigned site,
really the only thing that
I could see that was
inaccessible from small
screens was the store.
So the desktop version had a
store, but the mobile version
really had no way to
access shopping
experience from the phone.
Another problem with regards
to basic access is URL
redirection.
This is something
I see a lot of.
How many people have seen
something like this?
You go through.
You're clicking on your Twitter
feed or your Facebook
feed and somebody shares an m.
link, and you open it from
your desktop browser.
We see this stuff
all the time.
Here's Microsoft.
Here's this.
Here's this, this this,
this, this, this.
This is pretty common.
And then, of course, we end up
at Mitt Romney's website.
If you're on a mobile device
and you share Mitt Romney's
website and someone clicks
from that onto a desktop
browser, they get this page,
which clearly I'm sure the
designers never intended
for the site to be
viewed in this way.
This comic really sort of helps
sum it up, a lot of the
problems of sort of maintaining
separate mobile websites.
"Hi, I'm a server.
Who are you?"
"I'm a browser.
I'd like to see this article."
"Oh, I can help.
Let me get it for you.
Whoa, you're a smartphone
browser.
"Yeah."
"Cool.
Well, hey, I got this new mobile
version of my site.
Check it out.
Isn't it pretty?"
"Sure, but you just redirected
me to the main page.
Where's the article I wanted?"
"What article?
Who are you?
Hi, I'm a server."
So it's really important, URLs
are extremely important.
And unfortunately,
the sort of m.
and tablet.
and all of those other
dots become
a maintenance nightmare.
In addition, coming back to our
splash screen issue that I
brought up earlier, this
continued to the website link
for Obama's site.
You could click on that all
you want from Opera Mini,
which is a proxy browser.
So all the client side stuff
gets handled by the server.
And as a result, you get hit
with a splash screen and you
can click on Continue to the
Website all you want, but you
can't get past the
splash screen.
It doesn't redirect you to the
proper home page, which is a
really big issue.
All of a sudden, Opera Mini,
which is a very, very popular
browser, especially all over the
world, regions like Africa
and Asia Pacific and stuff like
that, they have no way of
getting to the site if they're
using that browser, which is a
pretty big deal.
So access is absolutely
fundamental.
Without it, you could make the
most beautiful parallaxy,
interactive website
you could imagine.
But if people can't access
it, they clearly can't
interact with it.
So let's talk about the next
tier of interaction, which is
interaction.
Obviously, there is a whole lot
of different ways a user
can interact with the site.
But I'm just going to focus on
a couple that I think are
pretty important.
So let's talk about
navigation.
This is my friend Quincy.
And my friend Quincy is
a good friend of mine.
And I say good friend because
I was able to peruse his
entire Facebook photo library,
pick the most embarrassing
photo of him, and post it
online, and show it to all you
people without asking him.
So that's how good of
a friend Quincy is.
So anyways, I recently moved
from New York City to
Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
And the day we were supposed to
move, or the day before we
are supposed to move,
my wife got really,
really, really sick.
And she was supposed to drive
the car across, and help pack
and all of that stuff.
Our friend Quincy went out of
this way and said, I could
help you guys out.
And he took his entire weekend
off and drove over with us and
helped us move.
So yeah, Quincy is
a good friend.
But the thing is, is that we
don't really see Quincy all
that often.
We maybe see him once a month
or once every other month.
So it's a pretty big deal for
him to help us out like that.
So what does this have to
do about navigation?
I think that navigation should
be like Quincy, where it's
there when you need them
but cool enough to
give you your space.
Whenever a navigation
is absent, obviously
that's a big deal.
But if the nav is always
in your face--
this is an example of a
responsive website.
All these different pages, these
are different pages of
the website you can see by
the little active state.
But the navigation's
just in your way.
You're not able to get to the
core content of the website.
It becomes that friend that's
just always hanging around or
always annoying and just
sort of asking you
what you're up to.
Hey, want to hang out?
Hey, want to go to the movies?
Hey, want to go to branch?
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
It's annoying, right?
So you want navigation to be
accessible, but you also want
it to be out of the way.
So if you look at Obama's
navigate, the previous
addition of Obama's website
utilized the sort of
Facebook-like slide-out
method.
If you're on a small screen, it
slides out from the left.
And whenever space becomes
available, it simply stacks
the links across the top.
So my friend Stephanie
[INAUDIBLE]
took a look at the navigation
and tested it out whenever it
first came out.
And she found some pretty
troubling things.
She said, "And the
menu failed.
Never even opened.
Suddenly, the site was without
navigation at all."
She tested on a lot of
different devices.
She found that it only worked on
the Galaxy Nexus, which at
the time, had just come
out, and an iPhone 4
with running iOS 5.
Where it didn't work, as you
could see, is a whole lot of
different environments.
And so she wrote about
this in a [INAUDIBLE]
for progressive enhancement.
And I have to say that I
totally agree with her.
A lot of people think of
JavaScript support as being
very binary.
And people say things like, oh,
of course users don't have
their JavaScript turned
off anymore.
That's very 1998 of
you to think that.
But whenever you look at
instances like this where
JavaScript has failed in some
way, shape, or form, but all
of these different devices are
actually quite capable from a
JavaScript point of view, the
idea is just about providing
an adequate fallback
if things go wrong.
This is me testing Obama's
site on a BlackBerry.
And if you note in the top left
corner, that's where the
menu button should be.
And there's no way of getting
to the navigation.
It just is entirely invisible
or absent.
These are big deals.
So thankfully, whenever Obama
redesigned his website, they
did something a little more
clever utilizing the footer
anchor technique where you
basically click a link in the
header and it jumps you down to
the footer of the website
where the navigation lives.
And also, using the
multi-toggle, which is
basically just nesting
sub-navigation items in little
accordions or sort of nesting
them in there like that.
So the result of that is
something that's a lot more
accessible.
It works on more devices
and sort of avoids a
lot of those problems.
If we look at Mitt Romney's
website, you could see that,
again, this is the earlier
version of his website.
We talked about how it doesn't
include everything on the
website or on the desktop
version of the website.
That's a pretty big deal.
But it's also sort of weird
that the only navigation
exists on the home page.
The home page is sort
of this dashboard.
And all the other sub-pages
basically just link back to
the home page.
So there's really no navigation
on any sub-pages.
So it becomes sort of this
full-page redirect in order to
navigate to another section
of the site.
So I wouldn't say that that's
very efficient.
In addition, you look at things
like back buttons.
If you look, all browsers
have some way of
going back in the history.
So that sort of back button that
you're including there is
a bit redundant.
So again, if we look at the
updated version of Romney's
website, we see he's utilizing
what's called the toggle,
where it basically
says Open Menu.
You tap that, it exposes
the navigation.
And then is says, Close Menu.
So again, that's a pretty good
way of keeping things
accessible, yet still
unobtrusive.
So definitely a step in the
right direction for him.
Another interaction that doesn't
really get talked
about a lot is that
of scrolling.
It's a pretty common
interaction, obviously. .
But it's also not terribly
sexy to talk about.
But what I found is that
whenever we scroll on mobile,
whether on the web or just
anywhere else in apps or
whatever, we're typically doing
one of three things.
We're either going
back in time.
We're going through a Facebook
feed or an email feed or some
form of time-based grouping
of items.
We're going through grouped
items or we're diving in deep
into content.
So again, so we have things
like going back in time.
You're scrolling back in time
through your posts, through
your email, through whatever.
Going through groups of items,
things like categories of
names and stuff like that.
So I'm going through my contact
lists on my phone, or
I'm going through an artist's
list in iTunes, or Rdio, or
something like that.
Or I'm diving in deep into a
single piece of content.
I'm reading my email and this
Nigerian prince email looks
very attractive to me, so
I want to learn more.
So I'm going to scroll down.
Or I'm reading a really great
article on the web and so I'm
going to scroll down
to read it.
So what I've found though, is
that we're always scrolling
through a singular
content type.
This is important for responsive
design because so
much of responsive design
is how to--
the conversation is about
how to re-flow layouts.
What do we do with those second
and third and fourth
columns and stuff?
And typically, the answer
is to simply stack them
underneath each other.
And what I found is that that
just doesn't make for a very
good user experience.
So if you look again,
here's Mitt
Romney's site on the left.
And here's a previous version of
Obama's site on the right.
And you can see you have this
sort of big call out, this
Obama, Clooney, and you.
You have an email
sign-up form.
You have a couple touts that
highlight certain things.
You have his record in brief.
And then, as you scroll down--
sorry about that.
Oh, doesn't seem to work.
But as you scroll down
this page, you
have all of this stuff.
You have the record in brief.
Then you get down to
his blog posts.
And you see the blog posts and
you see all these share icons
for each blog posts.
And it goes through about
10 different blog posts.
And then underneath,
there's a bunch of
things like his tweets.
And then underneath that,
it's like take action.
it's even more stuff.
And then eventually, you get
down to the footer where it
just contains this huge
spray of links.
And the idea is that you're
simply sifting through all of
this disparate content just to
find what you're looking for.
It's not a very good
user experience.
Again, like the user expectation
on a mobile device
is to scroll through a
single content type.
And by simply stacking things
on top of each other, users
are forced to go on a treasure
hunt just to find what they're
looking for.
So we want to avoid that.
And if we look at Obama's
redesigned website, they've
done some sort of clever
optimization where basically
on small screens they just
exposed the title of their
blog posts instead of showing
the full excerpts, and all
these images, and all
these share buttons
in addition to them.
So that creates a more scannable
experience a better
performing experience, and
all of that stuff.
So definitely a step in
the right direction.
Conditional loading is sort of
what we're talking about with
regards to how to solve
those problems.
How do we include a full
experience, especially for
larger screens, but still keep
things nice and compact and
fast-loading right out of the
gate for small mobile screens?
Scott Jehl calls this aggressive
enhancement.
I really love that term.
I hope it catches on.
But basically, the
idea is this.
We have a web page.
This could be any web page.
We have the thing.
And the thing is the thing
that's divined by the URI.
If you click on a picture that
says Click Here for Cute
Kittens, whenever you click
on that link, what do
you expect to find?
You expect to find
cute kittens.
But in addition to those
pictures of cute kittens,
there's all this other stuff.
We might have related pictures
of cute kittens.
We might have a comment form.
We might have social icons
to share the thing.
But all of those things aren't
the pictures of cute kittens
themselves.
So what we could do is
we can actually chunk
those things out.
Those sort of supplemental
or [INAUDIBLE]
bits, which actually,
again, might--
they might not all be crap.
It's not like you could just
remove them entirely.
But we can just be a little
more thoughtful of how we
introduce them into
the experience.
So what we could do is we could
simply chunk those out,
link to them from
the main page.
So link to the comments and
have them isolated.
So again, if JavaScript fails,
or when it fails, the user can
click Click Here to
View Comments.
And they tap that, and then
they get taken to the new
screen that shows
the comments.
So again, the idea is to
create an accessible
experience.
But then from there, we could
sort of pull everything
together, like Voltron when
the conditions are right.
Whenever the screen's large
enough to accommodate those
extra chunks.
Or whenever the user
requests them.
We could sort of just pull
everything all together.
I think that's a really, really
valuable technique that
we have at our disposal to sort
of help keep the core
experience really, really light,
but also not sort of
sacrifice serving up an
eventual robust web
experience.
So the next thing we're going to
talk about is performance.
Performance is, in my opinion,
very neglected.
And the expectations are high.
Mobile users expect mobile sites
to load as fast, if not
faster, than desktop sites.
And that's a pretty huge
majority there, 71%.
And a full 74% of mobile
visitors will abandon a site
if it takes more than
5 seconds to load.
That's a huge number,
a full 3/4.
So in other words really,
you have 5 seconds
of someone's time.
And if you don't give them
something in that 5 seconds,
they're gone.
And they'll oftentimes go
to a competitor's site.
And they will be gone
and never come back.
But the problem is, is that
the average page size just
keeps growing and keeps growing,
growing more obese
every single day.
Why is this happening?
What I found is that just
performance is invisible.
It's the sort of invisible
aspect of design.
You can't mock up performance
in Photoshop.
You can't sort of just put
it there as a line
item on your thing--
performance.
It's often this thing
that's just--
it's always there, but it's
always neglected.
So because of that, I've been
talking about elevating
performance as a design
feature rather than as
something that only developers
need to worry about.
Because very often-- and this
will probably sound familiar
to you, performance is
usually one of the
sort of lesser concerns.
Deadline's getting closer.
We don't really have a
whole lot of time.
It's like, oh, yeah.
We'll just worry about
all those performance
optimizations later.
Don't worry about it.
We just need to get
the site launched.
And, oh, that's just something
that the developers need to
take care of.
If the site's slow, it's
the developer's fault.
It's not the fact that they've
designed 30 meg images and
included a bunch of crazy
parallax stuff.
So I've been talking about
performance as design.
We need to elevate it earlier
in the design process.
You can't just leave it at
the end of the process.
If you don't think that
performance is important, it's
important to understand that
performance is good design.
Good performance
is good design.
If you don't believe me,
just look at the
whole Facebook thing.
I had a lot of people-- and
whenever I mention that I work
in mobile, people would say,
Facebook suck, as if it was my
fault or something.
But they weren't saying that
Facebook sucks because the
navigation was unintuitive, or
that the timeline redesign
wasn't elegant, or that the
navigation wasn't cool.
They were saying it sucks
because it was just so slow.
So we really need to prioritize
performance in this
day and age.
We can't just sort of cross our
fingers and hope that 4G
and LTE and everyone's just
going to be rocking a FiOS
connection anytime soon.
We really can't bank on that.
We need to address the
constraints of bandwidth.
So if we look at how the
candidates fared, this is
typical web page on Romney's
site, the Pennsylvania page.
And I ran it through a
tool, which at the
time was called Blaze.io.
It's since been renamed, and
we'll get to that in a minute.
And what I found is that the
mobile site took 8.75 seconds
to load and weighed
687K, which is
actually pretty decent.
It's still above that 5 second
mark that we'd like to see.
But at the same time, the file
size is significantly lighter
than the average page weight.
Then we get over to the
responsive end of things.
Guy Podjarny, who helped make
Blaze.io, which is now
Mobitest, now works at Akamai,
found that 86% of responsive
websites serve the same payload,
or roughly the same
payload, to small screen
viewers as
large screen viewers.
So in other words, all these
mobile sites are basically
getting a desktop heavy
experience.
And so that's definitely
reflected in
Barack Obama's website.
This is again, a previous
edition of it.
And we ran it through the same
test and found that it takes
21.68 seconds to load and
weighed 3 and 1/2 megs, which
is gigantic.
And that actually creates some
serious accessibility issues.
My cousin, who's a geologist,
has a company-issued
BlackBerry.
And I asked him to fire up
Obama's website on his
BlackBerry.
And this is what he
sent back to me.
It said, request entity
too large.
In other words, it's saying, I'm
not even going to try to
render that page.
It's just way too big.
And it's funny to point out
that Obama actually has a
Blackberry.
So I was sort of curious to see
if Obama could access his
own website from his phone.
Hopefully he can.
But if you look at the waterfall
charts, on the left
is Mitt Romney.
On the right is Obama.
You could just clearly see that
Obama's site is loading
way more stuff.
Through the course of the
campaign, they both underwent
some pretty serious redesigns.
So I ran both of the redesigns
through the updated tool,
which is again, called
Mobitest by Akamai.
And basically, it fires up--
you could paste in any URL.
It will fire it up on a real
device and then spit back the
performance stats for it.
So how long it takes to load,
what the page size is, and all
the waterfall charts.
And you can provide some
screenshots and stuff.
It's a great, great tool.
So I ran Mitt Romney's website
through this tool and found
that it actually now takes 19.58
seconds to load and now
their mobile site weighs
1.6megs, which is giant.
Once upon a time it was sitting
around, like 8 seconds
to load and 687K.
And now it's huge and
it's bloated.
Now granted, they are
achieving content
parity a lot more.
But it's a serious step
backwards for them as far as
performance goes.
And if we look at Obama's
website, their redesign
actually came down quite
a bit in file size.
It used to be 3 and 1/2 megs and
they cut it down to a meg.
It's still on the heavier side
of things, and it still takes
18.76 seconds to load.
But at the same time, that's
a pretty big step
in the right direction.
So performance is absolutely
essential.
I think that we need to sort
of elevate its status.
We need to treat it as more
of an urgent matter.
Treat it as a design
problem rather than
a development problem.
I think that does a lot of good
as far as getting more
people on board.
Just include that in your
statements of work and in your
project briefs and stuff.
Just say the goal is to create
a really fast website that's
very flexible.
So the last little bit of the
pyramid is this concept of
enhancement.
Progressive enhancement
is your friend.
Just because we have more
limited devices, or legacy
browsers, or whatever, doesn't
mean that we can't capitalize
on all the new and great
features that are coming down
the pipes really fast
and furious.
But in order to do this, we need
to build up from a core
experience.
We need to embrace the
constraints first, address
those constraints first,
and build up.
You hear the term mobile
first a lot.
And really, from a development
standpoint, it's about sort of
addressing the constraints
of the mobile medium--
low bandwidth, small
resolutions, potentially
inferior feature sets,
and stuff like that.
And really just sort of build
up those experiences so that
as devices have more screen real
estate, as devices have
more capabilities, we're in a
position where we could simply
add it onto a core experience
in order to capitalize on
those features.
Instead of sort of assuming
things by default-- oh, of
course users are on a large
screen or of course users
support touch.
Or of course users whatever.
All of a sudden you have to
cross your fingers and hope
that nobody releases a
popular device that
doesn't meet those criteria.
So it's really, really important
to progressively
enhance experiences now
more than ever.
And really, what I say is that
this is foundational work.
Jeremy Keith wonderfully stated,
he said, starting with
the lowest common
denominator--
or progressive enhancement
doesn't mean designing for the
lowest common denominator.
It means starting there.
I think that there is.
There's a misconception that
if you want to do anything
advanced or whatever, you have
to ignore progressive
enhancement.
That's simply not the case.
It's just a matter of laying a
solid foundation and covering
your bases, and then building
up from there.
Again, we have tools like
Modernizr, that gives us all
sorts of different things
that we could detect and
capitalize on them.
Introduce more advanced
functionality if a device
supports geolocation, if the
device supports App Cache, or
WebSockets, or whatever.
We actually have these tools
on the server side.
This is Detector by Dave Olsen,
which actually is sort
of a combination user
agent/feature detection tool
that all gets handled on the
server end of things.
So again, it doesn't all need
to be client side when we're
doing this adaptation.
But the idea is to really
capitalize on the specific
device that's accessing
your experience.
And it's also important to
understand that different
users have different
expectations.
My cousin's BlackBerry, he's
not expecting this crazy
multi-touch CSS3 transition
web experience.
He's really just trying to
access some information, and
read some things, and
maybe fill out of
form or two, or whatever.
But he understands that he
doesn't have the latest and
greatest Android device or the
latest and greatest iPhone.
Whenever you make these stupid
assumptions, you
start looking silly.
"Fatal Error.
No iPhone, iPad, HTML5 images
available." I honestly don't
really know what that means.
But yeah, you're depriving
people an experience
arbitrarily is what's
going on here.
It's also important to
understand that there's a
difference between support
and optimization.
Unless you wanted to hole
yourself up in a cabin for the
foreseeable future with a bunch
of different devices,
there's no way you're going to
be able to optimize for every
single platform and
configuration and user
preference and setting
out there.
So you do, you need to draw a
line between what you support
and what you optimize for.
And it's important to understand
that difference,
just because I think a
lot of people use--
they sort of misconstrue
what optimization or
what support means.
And they say, well, we only
want to support WebKit
browsers, or we only want to
support the iPhone, and
everything else can
take a hike.
There's still a way to
optimize for iPhone.
There's still a way to optimize
for the best of breed
and most capable devices while
still providing some level of
support for those other users.
Just because you don't like
their configuration or
whatever, or it's a pain in the
ass to develop for doesn't
mean we have the right to
arbitrarily lock them out of
an experience.
So there's a lot of different
things that we could enhance.
This is the candidate's
website.
You have all these opportunities
to utilize
things like the right input
types for forms.
So here we have a zip code on
both Mitt Romney's site and
Obama's site.
And what they could do is define
these things as numeric
inputs that allow--
that pull up the right virtual
keyboard on touch devices.
That makes the form
a little easier to
load or to get through.
Here we have the newsletter
site on Obama's site.
And you're looking at
the email field will
actually pull up--
so they did that one right.
So they did input type
equals email.
And it pulls up the
little at sign.
It gets rid of these other
unnecessary characters, so it
makes it a little
more easy to do.
But then you go down into the
ZIP field and that should be a
numeric value.
And it's not.
So there's a lot of different
things that we could do.
One of which is, again, changing
the input type to
number, which is great.
But then, also adding this
pattern attribute to the
string, which basically pulls
up the bigger chunkier
telephone prompt.
So instead of just having the
numbers 1 through 10 across
the top like the previous
screen--
oh, sorry.
I don't have an example
of that.
You instead get these
big, huge, chunky
keys, which is fantastic.
Another optimization that's
really important to understand
is that these telephones in
which we're accessing the web
can make telephone calls.
And Obama's website is actually
using this to his advantage.
So they have this Call Tool
where people are able to make
calls on the candidate's
behalf and say,
hey, are you voting?
Are you registered to vote?
Who are you voting for?
And give their whole spiel.
Basically, from an old school
standpoint, you would have to
look at the screen and then dial
a phone number on another
device, which is hugely
cumbersome, takes a lot of
time, and there's a lot
of room for error.
But again, these mobile devices
can make phone calls
right from the device.
So the user can be on Obama's
website, simply tap that
number, and initiate
a phone call.
That's really, really clever.
Other things for the candidates,
like geolocation
is really, really important.
Things that battleground states
and location matters a
great deal.
But there is ultimately just
all sorts of things that we
can enhance.
Again, if we look at that
list from Modernizr.
It's a pretty extensive list.
And this is just
the beginning.
So wrapping up.
This is what I want you to get
out of this, is that users
don't give a shit if your
site is responsive.
They don't give a shit if it's
a separate mobile site.
They do give a shit when they
can't get done what they need
to get done.
Whenever they can't accomplish
their task is when they start
noticing what environment
they're in.
There's all of these different
things that we need to take
into mind whenever we're
creating these multi-device
web experiences.
And it's just important to focus
on the right aspects of
the process.
And it's important
to understand--
I took a lot of shots at the
candidates' websites, and on
other sites and stuff as well.
But this stuff is really,
really hard.
We're all trying to
figure this out.
It's important to
start somewhere.
You might have a current desktop
site that's big and
clunky and crusty and old, but
it's just out of the question
to do a full-blown redesign.
So these separate mobile sites,
while they might be
sort of shortsighted in the near
term, can be a tremendous
opportunity to help you sort of
evolve out from under your
old legacy desktop site.
So while a mobile site might be
initially limited as far as
its content goes, as far as its
functionality goes, and
stuff like that, you can still
plant the seed for a
responsive future.
And that's exactly what a lot
of organizations are doing.
And eventually, you put time.
You put effort into it.
And ultimately, you can sort
of evolve out of your old
crusty desktop site and into
this new global site that's
mobile first built.
It's adaptive.
It's future-friendly.
That's exactly what
organizations like the BBC are
doing, like "People"
magazine are doing,
and stuff like that.
It just doesn't make sense for
them to strip away their old
desktop site just yet.
But at the same time,
they're learning how
to deal with diversity.
They're learning all the quirks
and the tricks of the
trade with regards to
the mobile web.
The takeaway from that is
to just start somewhere.
Even if you don't fundamentally
agree with
creating separate mobile sites,
that's OK as long as
you're planning on sort of
treating it as a stepping
stone for future enhancements.
And again, this stuff is
really, really hard.
And there's a lot to
learn from a lot
of different people.
So it's really important to not
get hung up in specific
implementations and technique.
I think that we need to sort
of stand together on
principles that we could
all agree on.
We all believe in the web.
I like to say, this ain't
religion, this is web design.
So be willing to abandon a best
practice that you've been
using your whole career whenever
you find evidence
that it makes sense
to abandon.
I really like this quote
from Benjamin Franklin.
He says, "Whenever you're
finished changing, you're
finished." And that means we
can't get hung up in our ways.
We can't get religious about
certain techniques and say,
this is the one right
way to do things.
We need to constantly
be evolving.
Again, if you think of all the
different devices that are
coming out just in the last
couple months, we need to be
evolving right there
with them.
Because the minute we
don't, the minute we
put the web at risk.
And let's face it, this
is going to be
really, really fun.
I can't think of a better
problem to help someone then
determining who the web can
reach, what it can do, where
it can go, how it gets used,
and why is still matters.
I think that's a tremendous
problem to have and just a
really, really fun problem
to help solve.
So with that, I would
like to say, I kept
politics out of this.
But I did cast my vote for the
candidate that I thought had
the best website.
And that is why I voted for
Jimmy McMillan's "The Rent is
too Damn High" party.
It's ample use of Comic Sans,
and loud borders, and animated
GIFs, it won me over.
So I had to vote for him.
I might have to change that to
2016, but I hope him and his
awesome website is
in our future.
So thanks very much, guys,
for listening.
Sorry for the technical
difficulties.
And hopefully we can take a look
at some questions now.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, absolutely.
So Brad, if you want to come
off screen-sharing and I'll
bring us up so that they
can see us both.
So one of the first questions
that we have that's got a lot
of votes, "When creating a
responsive sight, is it the
best practice to define media
queries in pixels or Ems And
are their pros and cons to
consider when using each of
those?"
BRAD FROST: Yeah, so there's
definitely advantages to
defining your media queries in
relative units, like Ems.
Lyza Danger Gardner of Cloud
Four wrote about this, about
basically how proportional media
queries are a lot more
future-friendly.
But also, present-friendly.
So in my experience,
I have seen pixel
widths sort of destroyed.
So a lot of different devices
handle pixels in a lot of
different ways.
16 pixels on a certain device
might look totally different
than 16 pixels elsewhere.
But also, user zoom settings
are really important.
If I go into a responsive
website and command + +,
magnify the site, which I
like to do actually--
if your media queries are set in
pixels, it won't honor the
user zoom settings.
But if you handle them with
relative units using Ems, it
will honor them.
I think it requires
a page refresh.
But at the same time, it
will re-flow the layout
appropriately if you use
proportional media queries.
And the other thing that's worth
stating is that we're
using proportional units for
everything else now.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah,
that's true.
BRAD FROST: For layouts, for
fonts, for everything now.
Just take it that one step
further and define your break
points in relative units.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So next question from Dan in
Amsterdam wants to know,
"Should we take into account
a device bandwidth before
serving content, especially
media assets to the device?
If so, how should we
implement that?"
BRAD FROST: Yeah, so there's a
lot of actually really recent
things that have been coming up
regarding sort of bandwidth.
It's still really tricky
to detect bandwidth.
We have sort of the navigation,
navigator
connection type, and
stuff like that.
But even that's not reliable.
Anybody that's been on like
hotel Wi-Fi will probably know
that 3G is oftentimes
faster than that.
We can't make assumptions even
based on even knowing what
kind of connection
type we have.
So I'd say that it's best to
assume a slow, painfully slow
connection by default and serve
up assets appropriately.
Things like adaptive images--
and there's a lot of different
solutions and stuff that's
sort of coming down the pipes
with regards to the spec and
stuff like that.
But in the meantime, we have
tools like Picture Fill, which
allows us to serve a small
image by default.
But then whenever you reach
a certain break point or
whatever, then load in
a larger image asset.
Same thing with retina graphics
and stuff like that.
Small by default, but then
conditionally load in a higher
res version.
But one of the most recent
things that has been pretty
clever is that they're finding
that the image compression,
like JPEG compression, is more
a factor in determining a
device's bandwidth--
or, I'm sorry, an image's size
than the dimensions of them.
So everyone's freaking out about
retina screens and stuff
like that now.
And it's important to understand
that you could
actually create larger images
with larger dimensions, but a
lower compression and then just
simply scale them down
and they'll look great on retina
displays, as well as
just standard displays.
And in some cases, the file
size of the enhanced--
the bigger--
PETE LEPAGE: Is even smaller.
BRAD FROST: Even smaller than
the base image, which is
pretty crazy.
But yeah, image optimization,
other things like maps and
other interactive components,
just don't include those
things by default.
Again, I was talking about
conditionally loading.
I will give my little example.
I have a demo of this
on the way.
Hopefully I can share
it later on--
of something like Google Maps.
If you want to embed Google Maps
in your site, you have to
iFrame in the embedded map.
But for small screens, I would
actually argue that's not a
very good experience.
For one, a lot of major
smartphone platforms, like iOS
and Android, will intercept
links to Google Maps and fire
up the native mapping
application, which is a far
better user experience
than anything
on the web can provide.
Again, it just has access
to more things.
So I'd say that that's
the best experience.
So the demo that I have
simply includes a
link to Google Maps.
And you could use the Google
Static Map API or whatever, to
pull in a still or whatever,
if you want to.
And then whenever the screen
size becomes big enough, then
you can load in that iFrame and
add an editable map and
stuff like that.
So again, it's about sort of
serving the right experience
to the right context
and stuff.
But by assuming less upfront,
you're not forcing mobile
users to download all this
JavaScript to render an iFrame
by default.
And as a result, you're able to
just sort of take bandwidth
into consideration.
At the very least, if everything
fails, they have a
link to Google Maps, and I'd
trust Google Developers on the
Maps mobile team more than me
to make sure that people can
get to where they need to get.
PETE LEPAGE: Absolutely.
Cool.
Well, Brad, I think that's about
all the time that we
have for today.
I want to say thank you so
much for joining us.
This was enlightening.
This is the second time I've
seen this session and I
learned stuff again
this second time.
So I want to say thank
you very much.
I want to invite all of our
viewers to join us in 3 weeks
on December 5.
We're going to have another
Chrome Mobile event where
we'll be talking about some of
the tools that you can use as
a developer building mobile
sites and mobile applications.
So with that, thank you
guys very much.
Brad, thank you.
BRAD FROST: Cool.
Thank you very much
for having me.
Appreciate it.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Have a good day, everybody.
BRAD FROST: All right,
take care.
PETE LEPAGE: Bye.
BRAD FROST: Bye.